gastard vous secours elle est pas belle
la vie
[Musique]
alors forcément cette semaine la grande
nouvelle c'est le type qui bat des
records de chutes déjà c'est un
autrichien pas la première fois qu'un
autrichien explose un compteur
c'est quand même dingue les gens ils
sont fascinés parce qu'un pauvre type
saute sur terre on habite cosmonautes
quoi ce fait c'est le truc si on a
marché sur la terre quoi enfin quelqu'un
lui a dit qu'il y avait de l'oxygène sur
la planète je dérive manquait plus que
ça je crois qu'il ya des traces d'eau et
était bon pour le rayon psychiatrique
sainte-anne
pas franchement c'était quoi ce machin
lancement de la fiac est vraiment des
gens qui ont rien à faire pas l'autre
qui fanfaronne perché dans un testicule
accroché un ballon mollement gonflé on
aurait dit le vrai portrait de françois
hollande
alors ok ok alors à près d'accord c'est
le premier mec qui a passé le mur du son
de l'altitude laquelle il a sauté le
même une chèvre elle aurait passé
d'ailleurs cette semaine n'était pas le
seul héros aussi à passer le mur du son
bon il devait vraiment aller vite parce
que sa parole a mis cinq mois à arriver
pour dire quoi pour recadrer peillon ça
c'est un vrai exploit c'est arrivé à se
faire recadrer par du vide quoi
héros quel culot de déclarer je ne suis
pas premier ministre par hasard
merci de nous prévenir on n'était pas au
courant
ça c'est sûr qu'il n'est pas là par
hasard c'est quand même grâce à lui
qu'on arrive à croire au charisme de
hollande
une façon moi je comprends peillon on
donne souvent du shit aux gens aux soins
palliatifs c'est normal qu'on enfile à
l'éducation nationale
dans les classes ça va être bien ça
avant les cours 15 minutes de fumée est
obligatoire pour tout le monde ça être
vachement plus détendu tout va puis les
profs il aura un vrai moyen de réprimer
les élèves huawei n'en arrête de faire
le con sinon j'achète plus chez toi quoi
[Musique]
façon y'a qu'la sanctions économiques
qui marche on sait bien qu'il faut dire
le trafic de drogue c'est quand même le
seul moyen pour des jeunes issus de
milieux défavorisés de rencontrer des
gens haut placés
vous êtes d'accord
enfin les artistes d'entrepreneurs des
avocats des procureurs fin du suspense
et après ça dépend de la drogue que tu
dis si c'est de la co que tu rencontres
des gens de pouvoir si tu deal du shit
tu rencontres des écolos
alors cette semaine enfin une écolo
glamour merci merci de mettre un peu de
vie quoi ça nous change d'eva joly
le pôle potes de la biomasse moi c'est
bon
alors c'est pas tout on a découvert un
truc il paraît qu'elle vend des sextoys
écolo
alors bon moi j'ai regardé en tant que
journaliste que je ne suis pas qu'est ce
que c'est un sextoy color essais des
canards sans phtalates ça en dit long
sur la sexualité des écolos
alléché chez eux les canaris les font
pas vibrer il est ma chemise
avec les godemichés ils font quoi est ce
qu ont les oreilles avec
les inquiétants après la panoplie alors
j'ai lu un
lubrifiant à nahla halle extraits
naturels des corses de goyave mois elles
vont en somme c'est bon ça lingerie bio
alors je passe avec le string enchantait
le machin et manque plus que les boules
de geisha fourni avec un récipient à
composter la cyprine
peu de délicatesse dans ce monde de
brutes
internationale aucun rapport la corse
bon marseille mais en version bucolique
comme plus jolie mais la corse cet
endroit merveilleux où dès que tu as une
maison et est persuadé que colonna est
innocent
mais bon encore c'est un pays où on
prend tous au pied de la lettre c'est
vrai la preuve chez eux il ya une vraie
saison morte
quinze morts depuis le début de l'année
s'est pas non plus je veux dire en syrie
quand il ya 15 morts par jour les gens
et 10 c en train de s'arranger
bon évidemment tout le monde s'en fout
de la série a raison encore un pays qui
a mal choisi ses voisins je suis désolé
quand tu es d'accord d'être entouré par
la turquie israël le liban l'irak et
l'iran enfin c'est que tu aimes avoir
des problèmes
à propos de voyage la syrie se doit vous
parlez vous lopez le voyagiste nature et
découverte
de la star en mal de l'altruisme
ethnologique
en tout cas une votre émission de
prouver un truc c'est que il n'y a pas
de star dans les pays pauvres parce que
la version retour existe pas quoi
et je me suis demandé pourquoi vous
emmener toujours les gens chez des
pauvres
il ya personne qui a réussi dans les
pays que vous fréquentez
ça c'est juste le bon là après non mais
moi vous m'emmener un jour je sais pas
en corée du nord je préférais aller chez
les dignitaires du régime que celle des
paysans affamés quoi je veux dire ou
chez kim jong il paraît qu'il a une cave
superbe away ces maïs mais ça c'est un
truc c'est boire du petrus à pyongyang
en contemplant une statue de lénine
ça doit être une volupté qui vous
dépasse
sinon dans les infos un peu annexes bon
et les [ __ ] qui défile avec spa les
[ __ ] c'est l'excellent qui s'appelle
comme ça sous le toit c'est un mouvement
qui dit mais jupes courtes n'est pas une
invitation quand on voit les photos je
peux dire que le reste non plus
sinon sport le japon a battu la france
mais la france a fait match nul contre
l'espagne super c'est complètement
surréaliste quoi c'est qui qui les
entraîne salvador dali andré breton
la prochaine étape c'est quoi mettre
cinq buts au brésil et en prendre 22 des
îles féroé
des bonnes nouvelles sinon cette semaine
alors il ya la blague fashion week black
fashion week j'ai vu les photos que de
chemin parcouru depuis tintin au congo
et puis une bonne nouvelle l'europe
vient de recevoir le prix nobel de la
paix c'est à dire un truc jusque là
réservé aux pays pauvres
ça a du bon déclare
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus